Todd Phillips, the director of the upcoming
Joker movie has publicly revealed the first
official look at Joaquin Phoenix in the lead
role.
The surprisingly-stripped down image was posted
to Phillips' Instagram page with the one-word
caption, "Arthur."
Without the context of the upcoming solo movie,
you'd never know this was supposed to be a
portrait of the Clown Prince of Crime.
Save for a greasy hairstyle and a few extra
wrinkles, Phoenix looks a lot like himself
in the photo - but there's a reason for that.
Phillips, who has directed films like Old
School, Starsky & Hutch, and the three movies
of The Hangover series, isn't making a movie
about the Joker at the height of his powers.
Instead, Joker is expected to be a dark and
experimental story, reportedly centering around
a failed comedian in the 1980s, who snaps
and transitions to a legendary life of crime.
Phoenix is playing the Joker as an everyday
guy, and this glimpse appears to be from just
before his one bad day sends him over the
edge.
With that in mind, it makes sense that the
first reveal of Phoenix in character doesn't
feature him in the typical Joker look.
Here he's just a fairly normal dude, struggling
to realize his dream of making people laugh.
When he comes to terms with the fact that
his career may never take off, he takes matters
into his own hands in a decidedly theatrical
way.
It sounds pretty relatable, aside from the
whole "domestic terrorism" thing.
Phillips' big reveal seems to confirm a previous
report by That Hashtag Show that stirred up
a ton of hype.
In July, the outlet posted an article claiming
that the Joker's real name in the movie would
be revealed as Arthur Fleck.
Now that Phillips himself has mentioned the
name, it seems a sure bet that Mr. Fleck is
our leading man.
In the same write-up, That Hashtag Show also
reported that the Joker movie will see Arthur
moving in with his sick mother, Penny, and
later meeting a woman named Sophie Dumond,
who may be played by Zazie Beetz of Atlanta
and Deadpool 2.
Other reports would seem to corroborate those
details.
The outlet's most outlandish hypothesis, that
the Joker and the Batman will be revealed
to be half-brothers, has yet to be confirmed
or denied.
But we do know that Batman's father, Thomas
Wayne, will be a part of the movie - so perhaps
there's some truth to that tidbit as well.
A major part of the Joker's appeal over the
years has been his generally-unknown, constantly
shifting origins.
Aside from the 1989 Batman movie, which presented
the character as a gangster named Jack Napier,
the Joker typically hasn't been shown as having
a traditional backstory.
He's usually more of an agent of chaos with
a contradictory history that he routinely
lies about.
"Ya wanna know how I got these scars?"
Despite that history of ambiguity, the fact
that this movie appears to be nailing down
one origin story for the Joker isn't anything
to be alarmed about.
It's not meant to be a definitive interpretation
- just a different one.
The Fox series Gotham, a prequel-of-sorts
to the world of Batman, has also spent the
last few years playing around with the Joker-inspired
characters Jerome and Jeremiah Valeska - unhinged
villains who have frequently been teased as
potentially being younger versions of the
Joker we know.
But what's true in the world of Gotham doesn't
need to be true for any other Batman story,
and the same goes for this solo movie.
Unlike the shared universe occupied by movies
like Suicide Squad, Wonder Woman, and Justice
League, Joaquin Phoenix's Joker movie is set
to be a standalone film, existing outside
of established continuity to tell a radically
different story.
It's a new approach for DC Comics on screen.
And if it works out, we can probably expect
other alternate universe, Elseworlds-type
stories to follow - like the Soviet Union
Superman story, Superman: Red Son.
This alternate universe aspect is a big part
of what makes Joker so potentially special.
It gives Phillips and Phoenix the freedom
to be weird and take chances without worrying
about sequels, spinoffs, or what's going on
in the Batman movies.
It's a great first look at one of 2019's most
curious projects, and we can't wait to find
out more.
"You…
You just couldn't let me go, could you?"